SRIKANTH BELWADI: So
something phenomenal
happened around
this time last year.
About half of all web
traffic was actually video.
It crossed the 50%
mark when I was looking
at the stats of YouTube.
And about 300 million--
sorry, 300 hours of video
was uploaded every
single minute.
300 hours every minute.
And Red Bull conducted
the Stratos Jump,
and approximately
eight million users
were watching that stream
simultaneously, a single video.
And just last year,
YouTube crossed
about one billion users--
active, unique users--
every single month.
This was a big shift
that was happening.
And this was not just on the
distribution and the content
delivery side.
It was looking at what's
happening on the content
production side, as well.
So YouTube obviously
delivers low resolution media
for end user devices.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Thank you.
But the content that's
produced in the studio
is a very small
part of that, that's
actually watched by users.
The high-res 4K
uncompressed video.
Every studio produces
approximately 20 terabytes
of video every day.
And this content needs to be
probably stored for decades.
Actually, lifetime.
Probably centuries.
We cannot imagine
Disney's "Snow White"
some footage being
lost after 100 years.
It's just not possible.
This needs to be stored forever.
So it's not just the
content that's produced,
but all the post-production
that needs to happen on this.
Last year, I learned that
"How to Train Your Dragon 2"
required about 75
million computers
to render all the
frames with about 250 TB
of active disk space.
And probably more recent
films require even more
compute power.
All of this could have been
a very tractable problem--
huge amount of data, huge
amount of processing--
if not for this graph.
If it was a uniform
distribution of computers
over a period of
about one year or so,
all the studios
could have probably
gone ahead and built larger and
larger data centers, whether
[INAUDIBLE] their
business or not,
and still been able to
solve for this problem.
Look at how the rendering
hours was actually
used by one of the studios over
a period of six months of movie
production, and this
was how it looked.
This graph is a
nightmare for anybody
who's planning for
capacity or resources.
But it also makes a
case for public cloud,
where you can get
elastic resources,
where you can spin up hundreds
or thousands of computes
as required and
then spin them down.
But burstability, or this
bursty nature of traffic,
is only part of the problem.
This industry is facing
millions of media formats,
with all the codecs and
standards and end user
devices that this content
needs to be delivered to.
Hard release dates.
Irrespective of how much
resources are required,
the producers have set the
final release date as constant,
and get the resources
as much as required.
Complex toolchains that
changes all the time.
In fact, every
production almost seems
like starting a new company.
And distributed workforce.
Last week I was in India, and
there were so many colleges
and institutions where visual
effects and animation degrees
and certificates
were being offered.
There are tax incentives
distributed in different parts
of the world.
So studios are no
longer at one location.
And this workforce, which is
distributed across the world,
is probably working on the same
project and needs collaborate.
And somehow, we need to handle
this enormous, enormous data.
And this challenge of
data and processing
is not limited to one stage
of the media lifecycle.
The challenge is across.
How do you ingest this
huge amount of content
into storage to
where the compute is,
with all the bandwidth
and latency challenges
that we have?
How do you render all these
frames with these huge compute
requirements?
And also, how do you get
the software licenses that
are required, which have all
been probably provisioned
for on-premises till now?
How do you transcode
for this myriad device
formats that are there?
How do you archive this content?
And it's not just
storing this content
for a long time at low cost.
How will you be able to retrieve
this content as required,
and when you need
it, in minutes?
And distributing to
users who are worldwide.
So all these are the challenges
that this industry faces.
And Google Cloud
Platform is actually
investing substantial
resources and infrastructure
to address these very problems.
And the essential
cloud elements,
which probably we will talk
through through the rest
of the sessions today
is flexible compute.
How can you spin up, if
you need, as required,
tens, hundreds,
thousands of VMs,
and spin down when
you don't need them?
And pay for exactly
what you use?
Always available storage.
High performance block storage
that you find on public cloud,
but also, can you get the
same low cost of archival
but be able to retrieve
it in a matter of minutes?
Global networking.
Goggle has around 70 plus
edge locations and points
of presence across the
world, and connected
through massive network,
including submarine fibers,
and we are not telecom company.
And solutions for big
data and analytics.
And it's not just the
infrastructure investments
that are made.
Over the last year
or so, [INAUDIBLE]
have launched about
100 plus features--
externally-facing,
very important,
large, large features.
Some of them, for example,
the more recent ones,
very relevant for
the media industry,
and we will talk about
this through the rest
of the sessions.
The Nearline
storage, 32-core VMs,
integration with [INAUDIBLE].
We'll have a full
session on that today.
HTTP load balancing and more.
But probably you don't
need to know any of that.
And if there are
just three words
that you are going to take away
from all of today's sessions,
it would be these.
Our team, we are
working very hard
to make sure that the
media industry can
get a little bit of simplicity
in their already complex life.
How can we simplify
your workflows,
whether you're a small time
developer, a freelancer who
needs probably a plug-in
to their desktop host
applications, or a
large, complex studio
and you have a hybrid model?
You have an existing
data center,
but you need to burst to cloud.
How can we do all this in
a safe and secure manner?
Google has hundreds of
engineers, security engineers.
Many of them are PhDs.
That's their life--
working for you
to keep your data
safe and secure.
These are the engineers
who are trained to ward off
most sophisticated
attacks, including
from nation-states for Google.
They're the ones who will be
working on this for you guys.
And lastly, the economics.
The real promise of cloud, which
was pay for exactly what you
used, not for the entire hour.
If you used it for a
minute, pay for the minutes.
You don't have to make
large commitments.
The pricing should be simple.
And if you use more,
you should automatically
get a lower price without you
having to commit anything.
So throughout the next
four to six hours,
we'll try to address
each of these elements
through multiple sessions.
And I hope you'll
have a good time.
Google Cloud Platform
currently powers multiple media
companies, from small studios,
individual freelancers,
distributors like [INAUDIBLE],
Framestore, and even YouTube,
by far the largest media
distribution company out there.
And we believe what we're
doing can help you, too.
With this, is let me call
upon Todd Prives, who's
a Product Manager for Rendering
at Google Cloud Platform.
Todd came from ZYNC.
And over the last
six months, I've
learned so much from
Todd that I don't now
feel that I'm new to
this [INAUDIBLE] at all.
Todd?
[APPLAUSE]